Thank you, everyone,
for your time today.
Just a quick recap
of our agenda.
We're going to be starting
talking off, talking about some
of the challenges the
data science teams face
and how RStudio products can
help tackle those challenges
and how those challenges, then
help drive people to consider
moving to the Cloud.
And so then we'll
talk about some
of the different Cloud
options that are out there,
hosted services,
working with the VPC
provider, such as your requests,
Cloud Marketplace offerings
and doing data science
in your data lake.
And then I'll hand off to Kevin
for to do a deep dive on some
of the factors that you
should consider when you're
considering deploying
your software to a VPE st.
Then we'll wrap up and have
time for as many questions
as we can.
And as Sam said, any questions
we don't get to today?
We'll have a follow up
thread on our community site
to continue the
discussion there.
So we've talked to
many data science teams
in a large variety of
organizations over the years,
and what we've heard
from many of them
is that a lot of
data science teams
fail to live up to their full
promise of what they're trying
to achieve, what the
organization is hoping,
the value that the
organization is
hoping to get from this team.
And there's lots of
reasons for that.
And these reasons
tend to Group Based
on our conversations
with, again,
many data science
teams tend to group
into a few different areas.
Perhaps teams have
trouble creating insights.
Perhaps they have trouble
once they have actually
created those insights
to actually use
those insights to
impact decision making
in the organization.
Because ultimately,
you know, if you've
got a better way to do
things or a better way
to make a decision, it
only actually matters
if that gets implemented
and that actually
impacts your organization.
Or sometimes teams have
the greatest challenges
around actually maintaining and
improving this value over time
that they get some insights,
they create decision making,
but then it fades.
Maybe they find it
difficult to maintain.
So there are many
different reasons,
many different challenges that
go into these different areas
and things the teams
need to overcome.
Today, we're going to be
focusing on this third column
that silo teams lead to
often redundant work,
make collaboration
difficult. They
may spend too much
time maintaining
tools or too much time
rerunning analysis
because teams
can't easily deploy
self-service applications.
Or perhaps they takes
too much manual effort
to deploy and maintain
these systems.
And I'm focusing on
these because these
are the items that
are often addressed
by centralizing
your data science
and/or moving it to the Cloud.
So what we found is that
customers who have successfully
scaled their data
science team and the work
that they do and impact
of the organization
tend to focus on three key
attributes of their data
science, environment,
open source, code oriented
and centralized, and
again, in this session
will focus on the
centralized and Cloud aspect.
Open source, of course, is a
key part of our studios mission
and we find it
critical because it
eases recruiting and retention,
and training for new people.
And it's comprehensive
and interoperable.
Code oriented is a key part
of our studios philosophy
of data science.
Because code is flexible, it
doesn't have black constraints
and code, by its nature, is easy
to iterate and reuse and extend
and inspect.
But again, in the
session will focus
on the centralized
and Cloud aspects
because centralizing
your data science
helps reduce unnecessary
work for the data science
team makes it easier to
collaborate across that team.
Providing a common way
of deploying cell service
applications to
your stakeholders,
helps inform them, helps
drive decision making,
an impact on the organization.
And of course, if you're
working with open source tools
like R in python, finding
some consistent way
to manage all the
data science packages
and manage the versions
of that is critical.
And often that's easiest
if you centralize that.
So that it's common across both
your development and deployment
environments.
Now, these three key
aspects, open source,
code oriented and
centralized are
key aspects of what we
call series data science.
And we call the series data
science, because this approach
typically enables a
data scientist to tackle
the complex difficult.
And at least initially,
often ill-defined
problems that can really
provide value and novel
insights in an organization.
Now, the two leading languages
in open source data science
are, of course, are in python,
but on their own are in python,
certainly provide the open
source and code oriented
aspects, but they don't out
of the box on their own,
make it easy to centralize
your data science
or deploy to the Cloud.
And that's where our studios
commercial products come in.
Our products support the
development and deployment
of data science with
both and python,
and we have a modular platform
called RStudio team that
helps you centralize your
data science in enterprise
friendly way, providing security
and scalability, et cetera.
And so let's just talk
about that briefly.
Now, what is the data science
team actually need to do?
Well, there's two things that
they typically need to do.
And part of their work, they
need to create insights.
And then they need to
find a way of sharing
those insights to
impact decision making
in the organization.
And so typically, when they
create inscience insights,
they're using some sort of
data science Workbench some way
where they can use
their idea of choice,
whether it's Jupyter
notebooks or are
they RStudio idee
or voice code, you
know, all in a single location,
use those different development
environments to create various
data products using own Python.
These these typically
are tailored applications
or reports or APIs.
We call these tailored because
they're not off the shelf,
they're not block
blackbox, but they're
focused on the problem
at hand, focused
on providing the exact
information that decision maker
needs in their day to day work.
And that's one of
the big advantages,
of course, of a code
oriented approach.
You don't have any
arbitrary limitations.
You can focus on what
your stakeholders need.
And of course, once they create
these interactive applications
or reports or API,
they need a way
of publishing them, a
way of sharing them.
And so typically they
can publish these
to a deployment portal.
And once this is available
in a deployment portal,
the data science team can
now share these insights
to impact decision making.
And this typically takes the
form of an interactive web
application, say,
a shiny application
that can be shared
with a decision maker
or an automated
email report that
can be sent to
the decision maker
with the analysis
right within it.
So they have that data
within their inbox
or perhaps they
create APIs that can
be integrated into other systems
for automated decision making.
And it's critical
for both these areas,
for both the development
side and the deployment side,
that you have a way of managing
your open source packages
because this eases
the maintenance
and reproducibility.
And this, of course, is
where our products come
in our studio, servpro provides
that centralized data science
Workbench with a variety
of different developed
environments.
Our RStudio Connect
provides that deployment
portal where you can
share your applications
and APIs with your decision
makers and other systems.
And these may take the form of
shinee R Markdown down clumber
APIs.
Also a number of
different Python
frameworks that
we support things
like screenland and bokeh.
And it's critical
for both of these
that you have a way
of managing packages.
And that's where our savu
package manager comes in.
And it's these three products.
Our studios are repro connect
and package manager that
make up RStudio team bundle.
And of course, it's
critical that this all
integrates with standard
systems in your organization.
Kevin, we'll be
talking a lot more
about a few of these special
communities moving forward.
But the critical
idea here is there's
a lot of benefits to
centralizing your data science.
And many, many of our customers
do exactly this on prem.
And so the question is,
what then drives people
to want to go to the cloud?
There are several
different reasons,
often a key reason is simply
simplifying and reducing
the startup costs
for new data science
team that when someone
in an organization
is spinning up a new
team, Cloud is often
a way to really get that
team, get the resources
that team needs going quickly.
Perhaps they want to make
collaboration or instruction,
say, workshops or classes
between organizations
or groups, easier clouds,
a great way of doing that.
Perhaps they want to
mitigate the high costs
of maintaining their own
computing infrastructure.
This was one of
the primary drivers
originally for organizations
to move to the Cloud.
It is still a major factor.
Closely aligned to that is
scaling to meet variable demand
that if you were the demand for
your computations for your data
science computations
is highly variable.
You don't want to keep a
bunch of expensive computing
infrastructure
sitting around idle.
Instead, you want to push
that responsibility out
to the Cloud provider to
maintain that for you.
And finally, if your data
is already in the cloud,
then you want to reduce
time and costs in moving
the data to your analysis.
And rather than pulling it
down locally to do data,
science is often much
more efficient and much
less expensive to do that.
Data science up on the Cloud
directly right in your data
lake.
So let's talk about a few
of these different options
again, one of the
most common options
is doing a hosted service where
a vendor provides software
as a service.
We talking about a
couple of things.
Our RStudio does their.
The other very common
way of doing this
is deploying to a
virtual private Cloud
provider, such as
Azure iwc, and I'll
be touching on
that lightly here,
but Kevin will be covering that.
And a lot more detail
in the next section.
Third and closely aligned is
called marketplace offerings.
Again, that's very
similar in some ways
to deploying to a VPC.
You're running on the
Cloud providers hardware,
but here, typically,
it's easier to start up
and it's done on
an hourly basis.
And finally, data
science in a data lake,
such as cueball or data brigs.
So hosted software, a
service offerings, some
of the things that really
make these offerings great
are they're easy
to quickly start up
and they streamlined
collaboration.
If the members of
your team can simply
go in, put a credit
code in and sign up
for a month to access
some capabilities,
that's an easy way to
scale up very quickly.
Now, sometimes
software as a service
may have limited
functionality compared
to on prem, so you might not
have the full option that you
would have if you were
to install locally.
And sometimes, again, depending
on the service integration
with your data, internal systems
could be more challenging
or perhaps not even possible.
So a couple of offerings that
RStudio has in this arena,
we have RStudio cloud, which
is a hosted version of the R
RStudio.
Servpro, with RStudio video,
makes it easy for anybody
to do or share our teacher
learn data science using just
your web browser.
So the initial focus right
now for our fire Cloud
is primarily,
primarily for platform
as a platform for
instructor led education.
So if you were doing a workshop
in your commercial organization
or if you were teaching a class
on data science or statistics
at the University
level, RStudio Cloud
is a great solution for that.
And we have many organizations
using it for that already.
Another great focus for
us to be a Cloud right
now is enabling
academic research
by sharing among
different groups
is a handy way of doing that.
And there's a lot more
that will be rolling out
in RStudio Cloud over
the next several months.
So some of the great
benefits of the Cloud, then
nothing to install locally,
all you need is a browser.
You can share projects that
you create there with your team
or class or workshop.
And again, nothing to configure,
no hardware installation
or anything like that, just
a month to month purchase.
And there's various plans
available for RStudio cloud,
including free to get started.
Shani apptio is
another hosted service
RStudio provide this is a
way of securely and scalable
sharing your host,
your shiny applications
on a hosted service.
And so if you have a
shot in the application
that you want to
share with the world
or with a much
smaller group, you
can do that quickly
on Johnny apptio.
Again, various plans
available there,
including free to get started
in business on the website
to learn more.
The second major area of
cloud, second major way
of going to the
Cloud is deploying
to a virtual private Cloud
provider like HWC or Azure
or Google Cloud platform.
Now, some of the
advantages of this
is that you can pay as you
go for the compute resources
specifically.
Typically, if you're
deploying to a vc,
you've purchased the
license from the vendor
already, though not necessarily
depends on the offering.
Another great adventure.
You get the full functionality
of on premise software
because typically it
is on premise software
or a close variant of that
that's available on the VPC.
So for example, right
now, our RStudio Cloud
doesn't yet have the ability
to provide our Jupyter
notebooks in that environment.
That's one of the things we're
working on for the future.
But right now, if
you were to deploy
RStudio servpro to a VPC, you'd
have the full functionality
being able to utilize Jupyter
notebooks and JupyterLab
through the same capabilities
that you use the RStudio.
DPK also give you access to
specialized hardware like
cpu's.
Now, on the con side, it
can be difficult to maintain
this typically more
administration overhead.
There's a complexity of
things like carbonetti
that you might need to consider.
And Kevin is going
to be discussing
all this in a lot more
detail in the next section.
The other challenger on VPC
is that the cost can be high.
And variable, that you need to
really manage the compute cost
closely to make
sure the software
is only available
when it's needed.
Otherwise, it can keep
running in the background
and rack up your
computer charges.
Third, and then closely related
is Cloud Marketplace offerings
going instead of installing
on your own on a VPC,
you go to the or Azure
or GCP Cloud marketplaces
to spin up software
from a vendor.
Our RStudio has offerings
on all those marketplaces.
It's very handy in a
lot of ways because it's
easy to get started
quickly, makes
it great for proof
of concepts you're
paying as you go typically
for both computer and software
licenses on an hourly basis.
Again, very inexpensive
to get started.
And again, access to the
specialized hardware.
But like deploying
to a VPC, you need
to make sure you
carefully manage
the software to make sure
it's only when running,
when you need it.
Otherwise, you could run into
excessive hourly charges, which
means often, not
always, but often this
is best for short term
projects, especially if you're
collaborating between
organizations, because that's
a great way to provide access
outside your organization.
And then finally, data
science in your data lake,
great example of a data lake
is someone like cueball,
a partner for RStudio.
Cueball provides a data
lake with RStudio servpro
capabilities built into it.
And some of the
advantages here is
you can minimize the overhead by
running your computations close
to the data, avoiding the costs
of moving the data from one
Cloud to another
or down locally,
and also makes it
easy to incorporate
data science directly
into your data pipeline.
Now, on the con side, running
your data center in your data,
they can add some
technical complexity,
can make it a little
bit more difficult
to do what you want to do,
or at least a little bit more
complicated.
And again, you might run into
some functionality limitations
here that could be challenging,
depending on what the data lake
provider and the data
science provider have done
and how they're
working together.
Technically So to sum up
this section, ultimately,
it really depends on what
your primary goal is and based
on your primary goal, you can.
Different ways of
going to the Cloud.
Your primary goal is to really
minimize cost and maintenance
and start up time, then using
a hosted service is often
a great way to start
there, especially if you
have a small team or really just
an individual data scientist.
If you want the full flexibility
of an on prem solution, all
the bells and whistles,
all the capabilities,
but without maintaining
your own hardware
but still having the
flexibility to scale,
then deploying to a VPC provider
is often the best way to go.
Kevin, we'll be talking
more about that next.
If you're doing something
that's much more short term,
perhaps just a proof
of concept, you
don't want to commit
to a long time period.
Offerings on a Cloud
Marketplace by the R
are often a great
way to do that.
And again, if your biggest
concern is your data
is already in the
Cloud and you want
to minimize the overhead of
moving that data someplace
else to analyze it, then often
data science in your data lake
is going to be
the best approach.
So with that, I'll
hand, you off to Kevin.
Thank you, Lou, for that
very good introduction.
I really appreciate
that presentation.
So I want to talk about
more along the lines of.
Yy you might want
to move to Cloud
and what are some of the key
considerations that people have
when they move to cloud?
So this is a big decision
for a lot of organizations
to either switch from
on premise history
or maybe just
expanding their Cloud
footprint for the
data science teams.
Next slide.
The so typically, when
we meet with clients
and we're discussing
Cloud Infrastructure
for various different
data science applications
and primarily a
lot of time, we're
speaking about RStudio
team installations
and configurations
that we're considering
a lot of different things.
And the key kind of
facts that come up,
the key recurring themes
that we see coming up
are, you know, first
of all, assessing
the needs of the team.
How big is their team?
How much power did he need?
And do they really
need the Cloud
that they need to utilize
the Cloud immense scale?
And do they see a lot of
potential future growth
or unforeseen growth
in the future?
So do they need to be able to
scale their resources over time
in an unpredictable manner?
And this is where Cloud
is really powerful
and it's quite easy
or relatively easy
to configure your environments
to scale over time
if you understand where
your team is going
and what your needs
are going to be.
Another key thing is how am
I going to control the costs?
So we infinite scale becomes
infinitely scaling builds.
So this is a big concern
as you alluded to,
it's a pay as you go model.
But unfortunate means if you
use lots and lots of resources,
you're going to get charged
from lots of resources.
So controlling costs is
a very key consideration.
It's a much more
straightforward control
those costs when you
are the ones maintaining
the physical infrastructure
because you've got a very
defined view of what it can be.
But when you're dealing with
virtually unlimited resources,
your bills.
Can get out of
hand quite quickly.
So there's different ways that
you can mitigate against that.
And we've talked a little
bit more about that.
Another key
consideration, we work
with a lot of clients in
more regulated industries,
whether it's working
in industries
with proprietary
information or maybe they're
working in industries
where they handle
a lot of very sensitive
data around customers.
So pity that maybe needs to
be treated with a high degree
of sensitivity.
And this is a consideration,
a key consideration
that maybe slows up the
adoption of Cloud over time.
So typically, these industries
are lagging behind the more
versatile or the more.
The more the tech
industry is there,
maybe it's move a
little quicker and these
don't have these regulations
that they need to consider,
and so they often ask,
how can I secure my cloud?
And the answer really is as
secure as you want to make it.
And we can dive
a little bit more
deep into that in a few minutes.
Another key consideration
is, of course,
you're handing over the
keys of your infrastructure
to a Cloud provider,
and if you go back as
far as the early 90s.
And the tech boom
and there was plenty
of websites that were being
hosted by young entrepreneurs
in and their home offices
or bedrooms and computers
that they put on
their desks, and they
were hosting websites that way.
But with the immense scale
of these Cloud Infrastructure
companies, they're much more
sophisticated organizations.
And while you're handing
over the keys to them
and they're managing
the physical security
of your infrastructure,
and they're
able to benefit from
that massive scale
to really secure
infrastructure in a way that
is quite difficult to do.
And we can talk a
bit more about that.
And then the last
one on this kind
of ties back to our first
point with regards to scale.
And that is, how do
we adapt to change
and how easy is it to do that?
If if I architect a solution.
And I build this
and all of a sudden,
I see a huge uptick in
usage, and how can I
make sure that we can scale
our environment for our teams
in an efficient manner.
So that we don't
see any downtime
or we don't have very
lengthy delays between making
more resources available.
And again, this is somewhere
where Cloud can really Excel.
If you if you know
what you're doing.
So thank you.
You can go to the next slightly.
So when we initially
engage with our clients,
one of the first things we
liked to talk to them about
is we carry out a
series of interviews
with their key users
and business users
to try and get a better
understanding across all
the different
products that they're
trying to embed in their team.
So, as you mentioned, our city
approval for data scientists,
the people who are
doing the development,
work RStudio
Connect the platform
for sharing that information
with the users and pakman,
for sharing the
story, for controlling
the managing the kind
of security and package
management.
So I put together
this small matrix just
to give some of
those considerations
that we would like
to take into account,
so we're looking to understand,
you know, let's say if we take,
for example, our studio,
how big is their team?
How many was the
makeup, the team?
The context of the
team is there are
a lot of data scientists, people
running a lot of simulations.
How variable are the workloads?
What's the kind of
size the data they're
dealing with there to deal
with very small data megabytes?
Are they really a big data
shop or what kind of sites
are terabytes of data?
And also, the size of the team
definitely matters, right,
if you've got a very
small team, if you've
got a team of five
people, you could probably
handle your workload and a
much more simple architecture.
But as you scale up
your team or your scale
of the size of your
data, you might
want to consider more
complex approaches.
And that's where
Lou was alluding
to earlier with the cluster's
approach with Kubernetes.
And so of kind of
broken it up here.
And you can think about it.
And this is definitely
a rule of thumb.
And, you know, your mileage
may vary, as they say.
And this all comes
out as a result
of a series of
interviews with your team
and understanding your needs.
But smaller teams,
more simple teams
would benefit from
a simpler approach.
And those are the ones
in the yellow zone.
So if you're dealing with
relatively small teams
with relatively small
amounts of data,
you could probably get away
with a more basic or simple
approach.
Again, taking into
consideration how variant
is the workloads in those teams.
Are you seen a large
differentiation
and make an architecture
that works for those as well?
And the same with the red zone.
If you're dealing with
very large sets of data
or very large teams,
you're definitely
going to want to consider a more
complex approach because it's
just harder to predict what your
teams are going to have to do.
So maybe going to want to work
with a more scalable solution,
something that
conflicts with the needs
of your team over time.
And if you're sitting in
that orange area again,
you're going to have to think
a little harder about what
kind of workloads
you're running,
how predictable everyday.
And you might be sitting
somewhere in between the more
simple approaches or the
more complex approaches,
depending on the type of
work that your team does.
Yes, you can go to
the next slightly.
So there are a number
of different solutions
that you can
implement in the Cloud
to implement your architecture
from the very simple
to the more complex, as
you alluded to there.
There is something like a
quickstart image from most
Cloud providers and in us.
And I provided some
analogous examples
throughout this presentation.
In us, we have something
called an Amazon machine image,
and this is just a
pre-configured image
where you can quickly spin off
the machine and test it out.
So this is better for
maybe short term projects
or where we typically
recommend this be used
is in cases where
people really just want
to play around with
RStudio and see is it worth
investing their time into?
And so they can quickly
launch and test and get it up
and running without
too much work.
And so this is a good
for prototyping phase
or just kind of see what
RStudio is all about.
If you're maybe new to
that or you're maybe
new to Cloud and
see, does it work.
Well with your
different systems?
But it comes at a
bit of a premium.
And so, as we were
saying, you'd probably
want to make sure you don't
leave it on all the time.
You're going to get charged
by the R for your machine
and the license fees.
And really, if you're going
to go ahead and deploy
your RStudio in a truly
production wise manner
and a serious
enterprise situation,
you're going to want to consider
one of the other options.
And so the simplest
approach, you can take
is a virtual machine.
Deployed on the
VPC, w.s., we have
something called the
elastic complete code,
and that's their virtual
machine deployment.
And so EC2 instances
as they're called,
you can go ahead and
pick all the RAM and CPU
requirements that you
need, pick the right OS.
That can be a very important
consideration for some teams.
If you need a Red Hat
Linux environment.
Or do you need a or are
you OK with an open source
environment like a bunta?
You want to consider
them, do you
want to be highly
available or not,
and if you need
double redundancy,
this is something we often
recommend to people working
in the Cloud is RStudio
has a built in load
balancer that will
distribute traffic evenly
across the different machines.
If you've got multiple
machines running,
but you can implement some
double redundancy, which
is super important for a
lot of teams to make sure
that if the master
goes down, you
don't lose access
to your environment.
And so we use load
balancers in the Cloud
and every major Cloud provider
has some version of this.
And this possibly allows for
us to scale our resources
vertically.
So we can or we can actually
skated out horizontally
as well.
But if you're doing that, we
recommend the next approach,
which is khubani.
So just for those who may be
uninitiated, skating vertically
will be just increasing
the amount of RAM or CPU
that your machine has
versus skidding horizontally
is simply adding more
of the same machine.
But if you're going to
go with that approach,
we recommend going with
a cluster approach.
So if you've got a
larger team and you've
got variable
workloads, you might
want to consider using
something like khubani.
And so, again,
every Cloud provider
has your own version of this.
On Amazon.
They've got a managed service
called ambisonics or Amazon
Elastic humanity service.
And this is really
great for enterprises
that have very low workloads.
And also, if you want to version
control your environment,
you can use Docker to
containerize your solutions,
your environment and
scale is infinitely
to your team's needs.
So if your team grows, you
just configure your cluster
to grow with your team.
And again, utilize
those load balancers.
The final one here today,
I want to point out.
That's an inbuilt
feature that's come out
in RStudio in the
last couple of years
that some people
may be aware of,
and that's server
servpro launcher.
And this integrates
well with carbonetti.
So what this allows
you to do is put
in your regular environment.
So maybe you've got
pretty low compute needs
on an everyday basis
within your team.
So maybe you don't
need an experiment.
Maybe you're OK with
in these two instances.
But every once in
a while, you want
the ability to have
to scale up your jobs
to a much larger scale.
So that's where job entry
could be really effective.
And allowing power
users to run those heavy
workloads without bringing to
a halt to the base instances.
So if you've got
a team of 10 data,
scientists are all
working and they're
using their eyes to
insys and somebody
wants to run a really heavy
model training or simulation,
they can utilize this
job, I'm sure, and not
take down our time, the entire
ekta instance for everybody
else.
And so isolates that
workload from everybody else
in the team.
You can go to the next slide.
So pay as you go, only
pay for what you use,
this is one of the
great benefits of cloud,
but only if you do it right.
You can definitely
get this wrong
and end up with a
big unexpectable.
So some of the common
mistakes that people
see as you overprovision
your resource
and this comes down
to poor planning,
so you over estimate your
needs and you essentially
just by some percentage amount
overspend or have a machine set
up, an architecture set
up that is maybe just
a little bit too much for
what you actually needed.
And you can scale that down.
And if you're
monitoring that, well.
Another one is poor
planning, so most providers
will allow you to set limits
on your spend or limits
on how big you want your
clusters to get or limits
on what machines are
different people are allowed
to use and stuff like that.
And so if you're not planning
that or if you're not
utilizing it at all, like
I say, with clusters,
the cluster will
grow to as bigger
than he does the team use.
So if you've got a
team of data scientists
and you don't have any
limit, and they get
carried away with themselves.
You could end up with
a very large bill
at the end of the month.
And the last one,
as you alluded to,
is shutting down those
unused resources.
So what we see in
a lot of teams is
they use plastic, my
producer, to use clusters,
and the analysts will
turn on their clusters
and do their analysis, but
they forget to shut it off.
So if they're not using
scalable infrastructure,
and they're setting up a
lot of expensive machines
and they leave it
running overnight,
that can be a pretty hefty bill
in the morning for somebody
if they forgot to turn it off.
So you can definitely mitigate
against these problems.
So you can be very
tofteland about putting
your architecture.
And this is something
where we really
work a lot with our
clients on and making sure
that we spend a lot of time
in the planning phase when
we're not rushing into
implementing the solutions.
We really want to make sure
that the solution that we're
architected for them
is right for them.
Now And right for them
six months from now.
So it's the right
mix of planning
for what they need
today, but also
take into consideration
what are they
going to need in the future?
Make sure you're utilizing
diverse budgets and monitoring
and alerts.
Be very clever about that
and utilize that to the max,
because that's going to help
prevent any unexpected builds
or any surprises.
Categorize Azure spends.
Make sure that, you know,
if you are overspending,
you're able to
easily pinpoint where
in your system,
your overspending.
So you can isolate that
offending instance or cluster
and make mitigating
actions to that.
And of course, you need
to regularly reassess.
So you can plan as
much as you want,
but your team's needs are
going to change over time.
Maybe your team grows
or maybe your team
is downsizing a little bit.
And you can go with
a smaller sites,
but you need to regularly
come back to the.
You can go to the next slide.
The next key question is,
how secure is the cloud?
And like I said earlier,
it can really be as secure
as you want it to be.
So a lot of people
will think, oh, well,
if I have my physical
infrastructure in house
on the premise, that's
the most secure.
I can be.
But I mean, that's
not always the case
because you've got to
pay for the security
within your own premises.
You've got to pay
for security guards.
If you're really concerned about
people coming in and doing harm
to your infrastructure,
you've got
to maintain that
infrastructure and you've
got to maintain all the
firewalls, the security around
the.
If you work with the Cloud
Amazon and their shared
responsibility model or
different Cloud providers,
they will maintain the
security and integrity
of those physical
machines and they
provide all of the
software that you need,
that you could possibly need
to configure the security.
So it can be as secure
as you wants to be.
And that is a real
caveat, because you
need to make sure that you're
configuring your configure
your solutions to be as secure
as your requirements might be.
So if you have a very
high security need,
you need to scale
up your investment
in your architecture
appropriately
and in different
Cloud providers.
And I'm going to use this
again, as an example.
You've got different resources.
So you can have a VPC that's
completely private with are
completely private or
maybe completely public
or maybe a mix of the two.
And you could have
different instances
in each environment that
can speak to each other
across using what are known as
an Amazon and Amazon Resource
Name.
But again, and every
Cloud provider,
you've got this ability to allow
services to talk to each other
without having humans
have access to services.
So this is really powerful.
If you to utilize it,
serverless technology, maybe
have an entry point that
a human can interact with,
but the underlying
hardware, data
infrastructure they
can access, it's
only the actual
services on attributes
that they do have
access that can do that.
So if you go to next slide,
we can see an example of that.
And this is just
an example where
we've got to seize the private
subnets inside of them.
Ordinarily, these two
instances shouldn't
be able to interact
with each other.
But again, Amazon
provides the software.
You can use this
vecepia in connection
and make sure that
these instances are now
able to communicate
with each other.
So a malicious actor cannot
communicate with these private
subnets are the
private instances,
but you can actually configure
services to be able to talk
to each other.
And that can be really powerful.
And important for
a lot of use cases
and making sure that
your different systems
across your organization
are to talk to each other
without compromising security.
You can go to the next slide.
Again, just to point
out, this is an example
here of the AWS shared
responsibility model and just
really to point out that
it's up to your organization
to configure a
secure environment.
So that your portion of the
shared responsibility of AWS
will provide and maintain
the software and hardware
needed to do all that.
But you need you need
to take responsibility
for making sure that your
privacy and security is meeting
your requirements.
So if you're from a
highly regulated industry,
you need to consider that
there's also some governance
Cloud options that if you're
working in a government agency,
most providers have
an option that's
exclusive to the
government agencies.
And that can be very important
is that you can go to the next
slightly.
Again, want to keep on the track
of this shared responsibility
model, we're talking about
the stability of environment.
So if I don't have
access or I don't
have I don't control my
physical infrastructure,
how can I ensure that it's going
to be safe, that everything's
going to be safeguarded?
And what happens if
there is a disaster.
And I'm not going
to lose all my data
and will lose all my services?
And again, you really can
take advantage of the scale
of the Cloud in this sense.
So, yes, if you were to
architecture solutions poorly.
And that's your portion of the
shared responsibility model,
you can expose yourself to
instability within the Cloud
Infrastructure.
So you want to make
sure when you're
protecting your
solutions that you're
taking advantage of
some of the features
that Cloud providers have.
So in the case of us,
they've got many regions
around the world,
dozens of them,
and they're constantly
adding these regions.
And they also don't have
within those regions
many different
availability zones.
These are geographically
distinct areas
within those geographically
distinct areas.
And finally, windows,
they have data centers
and these are where your
actual machines live.
So if you want to make sure that
you aren't hit by a disaster.
And you lose all your data,
you lose all of your computer
or you lose access
to your systems,
you can act tech solutions
that mitigate firtash.
And in that way, the Cloud
can be way more scalable
and way more secure and stable
than any on premise solution
could ever be if you take
advantage of this Cloud.
That means you just got
to architect it carefully.
And if you go to the next
slide, we can have a look here.
And you can see, yeah, we
can go and we can make sure
if we need if we
have a global team
and we want this highly
available environment,
we want to make sure that
we've got our systems mirrored
across many different regions.
So that means if something
happens in the Oregon region.
And one of the data centers
experiences a big outage,
which kind happen,
it's OK because we've
got a murder environment
inside of North Virginia.
And so our analysts,
our data scientists
who continue to do
the work, you also
want to make sure you're
setting up disaster recovery
effectively.
So that, you know, if
you do have one region,
still make sure you're backing
up your data in separate areas,
especially if you've got
mission critical information
in your infrastructure.
So just maybe just
making that point
that data centers confort
kornfield machines can fail.
This is the reality.
Cloud providers take advantage
of that scale and the expertise
they have in-house to
mitigate against that.
And reduce that down
as much as they can.
But it's on you to
make sure that you
architect solutions that
also prevent that as much as
possible.
OK, you can go to next slide.
And just the
closing remarks then
on architecting klowden,
the different solutions.
This time back to again,
that idea of scale and you
can plan as well as you want.
And you can build
your team out or you
can your whether as well as you
want around your current needs
and maybe even
project your needs.
A little bit into the future.
But oftentimes what
we see is people
want to be very conservative.
They're like, oh,
I don't know how
this is going to get adopted.
And and behold, because
it's such great software,
especially do a team
connect is something
that sees a lot of adoption once
it starts getting circulated
within organizations.
Suddenly your demand for
those services would spike.
And so you want to be able to
respond to that effectively.
Now, if you're using
on premise servers,
you're using physical
infrastructure in your house.
That means you have
got to go and you
got to call up your hardware
provider and order new machines
and have them
shipped to your site.
And then have your
IoT team install them
and configured them and
install the software on.
And it's a time like this.
You're adding weeks onto
your process with Cloud.
If you're clever and you've
automated your deployments
in an effective way, which you
can do with stuff like Cloud
formation, it means that, yeah,
I can scale up my architecture
as quickly as I want to get
it, scale up and take advantage
of that infinite
scale in the team.
So if you're planning
on a lot of scale,
you don't consider
that maybe you
need to use a cluster approach.
If you think your team's
really going to grow or just
be aware of the different
growth that your team might
experience.
And take advantage
of the monitoring
that a different
Cloud providers have
to monitor that usage of Cloud.
What you can really
monitor to monitor that.
And our your professional
has inbuilt monitoring.
So you can build custom
monitoring solutions,
but keep a close eye
on usage patterns
and understand when you
need to scale it up.
And then if you've got a clever
architecture cloud, Cloud
engineer, you can
easily scale up
your solutions, which
without that time
lag of ordering and procuring
the physical infrastructure.
And I think that's
the last slide,
if you go to the next one,
just to highlight that,
as I mentioned, trovatore,
because you are a full service
partner with our studio, what
that means for us is it means
we're licensed to resell the
different RStudio products,
but we also do training
and implementation
and configuration of
our team environment.
So we work with clients to
architect our solutions.
And we have people then who
are qualified and trained to go
in and install and
configure those solutions
and maintain those solutions
over a long period of time,
as teams learn to control
their own environments.
And that is the end of
that presentation Lou.
Great, thanks, Kevin.
And just a quick
Word on RStudio.
I'm sure you know who RStudio
is if you're listening
to this webinar, but
you might know us best
through open source work.
Things like creating
and maintaining
the set of packages to
make are easier to use
and easier to learn
how many applications
for creating web based
applications from R Markdown
to deliver essentially
our notebooks
to deliver reproducible,
interactive, R
based reports and
presentations and documents,
as well as our idy.
And certainly creating and
supporting this open source
software is and will continue
to be our studios core mission.
In fact, we announced
earlier this year
that we've reorganized
ourselves as a public benefit
corporation, which means
that now our open source
mission, our commitment to this
is codified into our business
charter.
And all our decisions
as an organization
must balance the interests
of all our stakeholders,
including our community, our
customers and our employees.
But an important
point is the products
that I was talking about at
the beginning of the session,
RStudio team really fund
our open source mission.
So that means by
buying our products,
not only do you
get the tools you
need to help scale out your
open source data science
investments, but you're also
helping support the open source
data science community.
And if you haven't
seen it, I strongly
encourage you to
check out the keynote
from jayjay, our CEO and founder
recorded at the last R studio,
where he talks about
our announcement
around being a public benefit
corporation and really
the philosophy of who RStudio
is and where we're going.
And of course, in addition
to our open source software
being used by millions
of people every week,
we have thousands of active
commercial software customers,
including 59% of the
Fortune hundreds.
And we're trusted by many of
the world's leading brands.
And so with that, you
know, Kevin and I'd
be happy to answer as many
questions as we can in the time
remaining.
Wonderful Thank you so
much, Lou and Kevin,
that was really informative.
It looks like we have enough
time or maybe for two,
maybe three questions.
So I'll go ahead and
just dive right in.
I'll start off
with the first one.
I think this is going
to be for it looks
like it be for Kevin here.
And how can you figure
out the compute power
that you or your team needs.
If you have not done it before?
If you're just getting started.
That's a really good question.
And there is guidance on
RStudio and we actually
have a recorded webinar that
I think might be shared out,
as well as Samantha that goes
deeper into the compute power
configuration.
So we did a recorded webinar
on architecting your solutions
for the cloud, where
we deep dive into how
you can configure that.
But there is guidance on
the studio, documentation
on the minimum requirements.
But I'm going to
go ahead and assume
that maybe the minimum
requirements aren't
suitable for you.
And so, yeah, if you
actually want to get started,
you're just
interested in learning
how you can do this, how you
can kind of get a good estimate.
We actually have a free
tool that you can go on to.
You can sign up on chorused.
Clear that come and on there.
There's and akuna
auto architecture too.
And this allows you to just
go in and fill out a form.
It's got some basic questions,
and it'll spit out then
at the end when you submit your
form suggested architecture.
So what machine sizes
it recommends based
off the input that you give.
And it's imperative
farm at the moment,
said my engineers would
want me to caveat with that.
So we'll give you
a rough estimate.
Definitely don't implement
straight away, but take
that is a good first step.
And optimize from there.
But that could be a really
good starting point,
is fill out that questionnaire,
generate an architecture
from that with different
recommended machine
sizes and types and
architectural diagrams that
go along with that.
And it even comes with some
terrifying scripts that
can help you quickstart on it.
If you're interested
in database's platform.
But other than that,
it's really a discussion.
You've got to consider
how much RAM you're
going to need if we were to get
into the formulaic part of it.
If you've got a lot of
data that you're processing
and you're doing a
lot of linear algebra.
And then RAM requirements
going to be very important,
cpu's are going to be
very important if you've
got a lot of concurrent users.
So there's lots
of considerations
that go into of
the different specs
that you might need
inside your machine.
Excellent.
Thank you, Kevin.
I think that's really helpful.
And then one more question.
So in the context of sharing
code, et cetera, and even
the data, what are
some best practices
for working with US
government requirements?
Most of this question, they
say all of our projects
are physically siloed,
even in our own VPC
and do not share space.
So, cavitat, Lou, what
would be some best
practices you might
recommend here?
I can actually go give
a brief description,
because we have been working
with a client similar to that
recently, and yet.
I feel the pain.
There is a lot of restrictions
on the environments.
And so thankfully,
these organizations
are kind of becoming more
open to the cloud, which
makes things easier.
And it really just
comes down to I
think if you work
with government data,
more Cloud providers,
as I mentioned,
have a government
Cloud option where
the servers are
completely isolated
from the public infrastructure.
So only government agencies
have access to this.
So you might want to
utilize one of those
if you're moving to the Cloud.
And as far as, like
sharing data information,
we've actually been
helping a client come up
with a virtual
cleanroom scenario.
So as you mentioned,
how can you keep
how can you isolate
data and code and stuff
like that from people?
Because you don't want everybody
to have access to that data.
You don't have access to
your proprietary code.
And there's a lot of
privacy concerns there.
And so you can use
something like carbonating
to containerize your
solutions and windows
containerize solutions configure
all the privacy requirements
that you need.
And if you can imagine
like a push button
exercise where somebody
presses a button,
and it automatically
launches a container
that has all of the access
pre-configured and associated
with their profile.
And so that's what we
call a virtual cleanroom.
So it essentially
means that everybody
who's working off
this environment
is completely they're getting
like a fresh, clean install,
a completely unperturbed
by anybody else's sessions.
And so it's completely
independent of everybody else.
And it's only been used by them.
And it only has
access to the data
that their profile should
allow them to have access to.
So that's one way we're
looking at helping clients
at the moment.
And one of the best practices
that I can see right now,
our future best practices.
So it's a really
exciting project.